want to be able to solo the most
difficult PvE content in the game with
ease keep watching and I'll show you how
[Music]
global event 3 brought us four new
classified sets to collect and the one
I'm going to focus on today is the d3
fnc set I'll be the first to admit I'm
not really a fan of shield builds I just
find them a little boring and
one-dimensional to play but for some of
the more difficult PvE content running
this build makes it feel like you're
playing in easy mode in a team this
build excels it's setting up front face
taking all enemy fire while your
teammates deal out the DPS however as a
mainly solo player I needed this to do a
little more than sponge bullets it's all
good staying alive but we need to be
able to do a bit of damage to a lot of
you'll be thinking why not just run the
sixth piece Nomad set there's a couple
of reasons I prefer to run the d3 of a
nomad one nothing is left to chance and
to win matchmaking or running with a
team you'll actually be assisting the
team with your build the default
increased threat that the ballistic
shield brings will have a lot of the
enemies focusing on you allowing your
teammates the freedom to focus down NPCs
plus should be providing a pretty decent
buff as your shield takes damage don't
get me wrong the sixth piece of Nomad
builds a hell of a lot of fun to play
but more skill is required to be as
effective as the d3 build this build
isn't ideal for every situation
activities like Dragon's nest and Warren
gate are a good example of this the
builds lack of range and mobility does
have it sitting as one of the more
boring styles of play but if you're
struggling to compete with tough NPCs or
your aim just isn't on point
you won't be disappointed with what you
can achieve I found this build
particularly strong in resistance where
if carried entire teams through the more
difficult waves though admittedly it
does fall a bit short when it comes to
the timed boss waves not because it
can't take down the bosses more that
it's a little slow to take them out
before the timer expires so it's best
complemented by one or two DPS builds as
per usual I'll be keeping this video
short and concise as possible if you
have any further questions please just
leave a comment section below at the end
of this video I've included a cheat
sheet that sums up this build and
everything discussed here
firstly we want to focus on staying
alive as the six piece bonus states win
at nine thousand stamina ballistic
shield health is increased by 200% with
this the shield itself will have a
minimum of 1.7 million health but this
in the 9,000 stamina alone won't be
enough even with another million shield
health feel often find yourself being
flanked by NPCs or under heavy fire and
legendary missions for example so we
still need to focus on character and
shield healing with in mind let's move
on to the gear and motts firstly health
on kill will be important to allow a
steady flow of healing so this has been
rolled onto the chest and gloves the
maximum you can get on these two pieces
combined is only 10% but we'll be
focusing on this more a little later on
next because all of your piece have been
rolled into stamina in order to meet the
six piece requirement we need to get
some damage out of the set damage to
elites has been rolled onto the mask and
kneepads and enemy armor damage on the
chest mask knee pads and gloves with all
this including firearms damage to elite
mods you should be sitting at around 550
K toughness 43% damage to elites 26%
enemy armor damage and 30% protection
from elites even with low firearms this
build can comfortably clear out even the
most difficult NPCs because of the
nature of the set you'll be constantly
at the frontlines tanking damage and
unloading clip after clip from your SMG
so your mo is going to run out fast
rolling mo capacity on the chest and
backpack pieces is a must with your
holster there's usually only a couple of
options worth rolling into skill haste
or health but because skill taste isn't
really required and you already have a
ton of health I suggest getting reload
speed the 22 percent makes a noticeable
difference to the damage you'll be doing
over time
the weapon talents on your primary are
quite important here I'm using the house
but any SMG will work fine
the recommended talents are predatory
and self preserved self preserved
synergizes really well with this and
Jesus providing a three percent heal of
the damage dealt from each critical hurt
teamed up with predatory that gives a
thirty five percent health regeneration
over twenty seconds and the tempest in
health on kill that has already been
rolled onto your gear you'll end up with
a bit of a health leeching vampire build
but this is key to helping you stay
alive
the secondary weapon really isn't too
important you only be using this if your
shield happens to go down or you need
some range for this reason I'd recommend
equipping some sort of marksman rifle
as far as the skills go the ballistic
shield is a given but with the second
skill you may want to mix this up
depending on the mission you don't need
a heal because you're as long as you're
getting kills you'll be at maximum life
anyway and your skill power is so low
that most of the skills won't be very
effective I recommend running either
defib for quick teammate revives or
overdose to top up your shield health as
any over healing your receivers instead
applied to the ballistic shield
the recommended talents are critical
save because if you need to use a mid
kit with this build you're probably in
trouble
so the 20% damage resistance will help
combat medic so you can repair your
shield if needed and one is none to help
reduce the amount of ammo you'll be
going through an optional talent is
precision to provide a little more
damage
I haven't really discussed the other six
peace bonuses like the buff that's given
after receiving a certain amount of
shield damage or the 2000 shield melee
damage increase not because they aren't
good but because they really don't
define the build in my opinion sure the
30% armor increase comes in handy and
beating an enemy down with your shield
can be pretty fun it isn't enough to
focus a build around anyway give this
bill to go and let me know what you
think it isn't the most exciting
playstyle but it will certainly help you
out if you're a struggling solo player
particularly if you're on console if you
found this useful and you'd like to see
what else I have to offer during this
new classified meter hit the subscribe
button and I'll see you in the next
video Cheers
you
[Music]